fragen wir nach bei Professor Albrecht
Lucke dem Politikwissenschaftler Herr
Lucke wie bewerten Sie dieses Video
ja man ist ja eigentlich fast sprachlos
und wenn wir nicht in solchen Zeiten
leben würden wie denen in denen wir
leben müssen mit einem Krieg brutalster
Art an dem kein Silvester nur eine Pause
den Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine vergönnt
hat wenn das alles nicht so wäre dann
würde man das ja fast als eine real
Satire begreifen können und müssen denn
es zeigt ein weiteres Mal wie ungeheuer
Instinkt los diese
Verteidigungsministerin ist man hat ja
fast den Eindruck der Authentizität
halber so könnte man es ja fast positiv
untermalen stellt sie sich auf den
Berliner Platz fast ausgebombt hat man
den Eindruck um noch einmal jetzt
besonders authentisch Bilder zu machen
nein das alles ist natürlich nicht der
Fall es zeigt aber wie derartig
unvermögend unfähig letztlich hier
geplant wird es wäre das normalste der
Welt gewesen mit all dem Wissen darum
wann Silvester stattfindet hier ein
ordentlichen Ort zu finden ein
ordentliches Video aufzunehmen mit den
richtigen Worten das hat alles nicht
funktioniert und so knüpft die
Ministerin genau reibungslos da an wo
sie aufgehört hat nämlich da wo sie
nicht den Instinkt hatte die Bilder zu
senden die in einer solchen Situation
aus ihrem so heiklen wichtigen Amt
erforderlich werden ja es ist dazu
Empathie frei den Ukrainern in
Deutschland gegenüber vor allem auch in
Berlin sind ja sehr viele Ukrainer weil
das ist ja im Geballer und geböller
aufgezeichnet worden es ist egozentrisch
weil sie ja von interessanten
Begegnungen und tollen Menschen vor dem
Hintergrund des Krieges spricht
aber es führt sozusagen ja über das
persönliche man kann ja sagen so
Neujahrsgruß kann sie ja machen die Frau
Ministerin aber es führt in den Bereich
der politischen Kommunikation was sie ja
schon angesprochen haben also dieser
Bereich der liegt offenbar bei Frau
Lamprecht im Hagen was sagen denn die
Vertreter der Ampel dazu ist es den
Sozialdemokraten die Performance von
Frau Lambrecht nicht langsam ungeheuer
peinlich
ja das ist das Mindeste was man vermuten
muss aber es ist natürlich viel
dramatischer denn wenn man es mal auch
da im militärischen Jargon fast die
Einschläge rücken immer näher an den
Bundeskanzler heran die Belastung die
Frau Lambrecht mittlerweile darstellt
und das war heute in alter Kritik der
Opposition mit Händen zu greifen die
Kritik richtet sich mittlerweile gegen
Olaf Scholz der ja eigentlich für sich
reklamiert hatte dass er diese
Verteidigungspolitik zur Chefsache
gemacht hat und er wird natürlich
entgeistert auf diese Unprofessionalität
gucken und das ist ja das kann der Kern
des Problems man fragt sich was eine so
angeschlagene Ministerin die er kurz
davor noch das Puma Desaster zu erklären
hatte wo sie letztlich alles auf die
Industrie geschoben hatte wie sich eine
solche Ministerin auf den letzten Metern
noch einmal derartig ein fatalen Staat
wie er Verteiler nicht sein könnte in
einem so schwieriges Jahr 2023
verschaffen konnte und insofern glaube
ich geht eher die Sorge um im
Bundeskanzleramt und ich würde die These
wagen wenn es denn der Fall sein sollte
denn das steht ja im Hintergrund dieses
Jahres
alles möglicherweise sowieso eine
Kabinettsbildung umsteht weil die
Innenministerin die ja ihrerseits nun
mit den Krawallen in Berlin auch
Probleme hat die nicht auf ihr Konto
gehen aber die sich als Innenministerin
durchaus mehr Meriten erworben hat als
die Verteidigungsministerin wenn diese
aber Frau Feser zukünftig
Spitzenkandidaten in Hessen werden
sollte dann muss ich davon ausgehen dass
dann auch eine größere
Kabinettsumbildung stattfinden wird das
Frau Lamprecht abberufen wird und dass
an ihrer Stadt Frau Högel eine ganz
gestandene Verteidigungsministerin die
bundeswehrbeauftragte dass sie dann in
dieses Amt auf rückt es ist letztlich
zunehmend ein Problem für Olaf Scholz
und ich glaube an dieser Stelle wird der
Kanzler irgendwann reagieren müssen
könnte das auch der Grund sein also das
hinter den Kulissen bei den sozialen
Demokraten vielleicht der Stühle rücken
schon geplant ist und klargezogen ist
könnte das der Grund dafür sein dass es
heute an diesem politischen Montag in
Berlin sogar keine Unterstützung für
Frau Lambrecht aus den reine
Sozialdemokraten gab
ja das ist durchaus denkbar man kennt
diese Verhaltensweise ja in gewisser
Weise kann man sich fast vorstellen
nicht dass sie bereits auf dem
Abstellgleis steht aber das so etwas
stattfindet wie ein Versuch dieses
Unheil von sich selbst fernzuhalten denn
natürlich kontaminiert so etwas
regelrecht also ein solches anhaltendes
Desaster ist etwas was wahrscheinlich
alle in der Regierungs regelrecht ratlos
macht konsterniert sein lässt FDP und es
und und Grüne haben ohnehin keine
Veranlassung sich hinter die
Verteidigungsministerin zu stellen das
werden sie als eine Sache der SPD
begreifen aber sie haben völlig Recht
auch aus der SPD herrscht ich würde es
eher so begreifen es herrscht entsetztes
schweigen und insofern glaube ich dass
wenn Frau Lamprecht nicht irgendwie noch
einmal einen neuen Eingang findet vor
allem Eingang und das war ja das Problem
von Anfang an Eingang der ihre
Motivation auch ihre Bereitschaft aus
Fehlern zu lernen unterstreicht wenn das
alles nicht stattfindet dann sehe ich
nicht wie das noch zur Erfolg führen
soll dann bleibt am Ende dann bleibt
variiert der alte Spruch ist der Ruf
erst definiert kriegst du ihn nicht mehr
repariert sagt Professor Albrecht Lucke
der Politikwissenschaftler ich sage
danke für Ihre Zeit und danke für diese
Analysen